dijo que estaba asustado. Yo no sé si estoy asustada,
pero ésta es la primera que me dirijo a un público como éste.
Y yo no tengo ningún tipo de última tecnología para ofreceros.
No traigo diapositivas, así que tendréis que conformaros conmigo.
(Risas)
Lo que me gustaría hacer esta mañana es compartir con vosotros un par de historias
y hablar de una África distinta.
Ya esta mañana ha habido algunas alusiones hacia la África
de la que oís hablar todo el tiempo: la África del VIH/SIDA,
la África de la malaria, la África de la pobreza, la África del conflicto,
y la África de los desastres.
A pesar de que es cierto que esas cosas todavía siguen ocurriendo,
existe una África de la que no se oye hablar demasiado.
Y a veces me sorprende, y me pregunto por qué.
Ésta es la África que está cambiando, a la que Chris ha aludido.
Ésta es la África de la oportunidad.
Ésta es la África en donde la gente quiere tomar el mando de
su propio futuro y de su propio destino.
Y ésta es la África en donde la gente está buscando socios
para hacerlo. De esto es de lo que quiero hablar hoy.
Y quiero empezar contándoos
una historia sobre el cambio en África.
El 15 de septiembre de 2005, Mr. Diepreye Alamieyeseigha,
el gobernador de uno de los estados más ricos en petróleo de Nigeria,
fue arrestado por la Policía Metropolitana de Londres durante una visita a Londres.
Fue arrestado porque habían transferencias de 8 millones de dólares
que habían ido a parar a varias cuentas inactivas
que pertenecían tanto a él como a su família.
Este arresto ocurrió porque existía cooperación
entre la Policía Metropolitana de Londres
y la Comisión de Crímenes Económicos y Financieros de Nigeria --
dirigida por uno de nuestras personas más capaces y valientes: Mr. Nuhu Ribadu.
Alamieyeseigha fue procesado en Londres.
Debido a varios errores, logró escapar vestido de mujer,
huyó de Londres y volvió a Nigeria donde,
de acuerdo a la constitución, aquellos en un cargo
como los gobernadores, presidente -- así como en muchos países --
tienen inmunidad y no pueden ser procesados. Pero esto fue lo que pasó:
la gente estaba tan indignada por su comportamiento que fue posible,
por el poder legislativo del estado, impugnarlo y sacarlo del cargo.
Hoy, Alams -- así es como lo llamamos de forma abreviada -- está en la cárcel.
Ésta es una historia sobre el hecho de que la gente en África
ya no está dispuesta a seguir tolerando la corrupción por parte de sus líderes.
Ésta es una historia sobre el hecho de que la gente quiere que sus recursos
sean administrados correctamente en su beneficio, y no extraídos hacia lugares
en donde sólo vayan a beneficiar a unos pocos de una élite.
Y, por lo tanto, cuando oyes hablar de la corrupta África --
corrupción todo el tiempo -- me gustaría que supierais que la gente
y los gobiernos están luchando muy duramente para combatir esto
en algunos de los países, y que algunos éxitos están ya emergiendo.
¿Quiere decir esto que el problema está resuelto? La respuesta es no.
Todavía hay un largo camino que recorrer, pero existe voluntad para hacerlo.
Y que estamos apuntando éxitos en esta lucha tan importante.
Así que cuando oigas sobre corrupción,
no pienses que no se está haciendo nada en ese sentido --
que no se puede trabajar en ningún país africano
a causa de la extrema corrupción. Pero eso no es cierto.
Hay una voluntad para luchar, y en muchos países, esta lucha está en curso
y está siendo ganada. En otros, como en el mío,
donde ha existido una larga historia de dictaduras en Nigeria,
la lucha está en marcha y tenemos un largo camino que recorrer.
Pero lo cierto es que está en marcha.
Así lo demuestran los resultados:
la supervisión independiente por el Banco Mundial y otras organizaciones
muestra que en varios casos la tendencia es descendente
en términos de corrupción, y que el gobierno está mejorando.
Un estudio llevado a cabo por la Comisión Económica para África mostró
una clara tendencia ascendente en relación a los gobiernos de 28 países africanos.
Y dejadme decir sólo una cosa más
antes de que deje esta área de gobierno.
Y es que la gente habla sobre corrupción, corrupción.
Durante todo el tiempo que hablas de ella
estás pensando inmediatamente en África.
Ésa es la imagen: los países africanos. Pero dejadme decir esto:
si Alams pudo exportar ocho millones de dólares a una cuenta en Londres --
si la otra gente que había tomado el dinero estimaba que
de 20 a 40 millones de fondos de países en vías de desarrollo
están atesorados en el exterior, en países desarrollados -- si son capaces de hacer esto,
¿Qué es esto? ¿No es esto corrupción?
En este país, si recibes bienes robados, ¿no eres procesado?
Pues cuando hablamos de este tipo de corrupción, pensemos también
en lo que está pasando en la otra parte del planeta --
a dónde está yendo el dinero y en qué podemos hacer para parar eso.
Ahora estoy trabajando en una iniciativa, junto con el Banco Mundial,
sobre el rescate de activos, tratando de hacer lo que podemos
para recuperar el dinero que había sido llevado al extranjero --
el dinero de países en vías de desarrollo - para traer ese dinero enviado de vuelta.
Porque si logramos traer de vuelta esos 20 billones de dólares,
podría haber mucho más para algunos de estos países
que toda la ayuda junta que estamos recibiendo.
(Aplausos)
La segunda cuestión de la que quiero hablar es sobre la voluntad para reformar.
Los africanos, después de todo -- están cansados, estamos cansados
de ser el sujeto de la caridad y el cuidado de todo el mundo.
Estamos agradecidos, pero sabemos que
podemos tomar el mando de nuestro propio destino si tenemos la voluntad de reformar.
Y lo que está pasando en muchos países africanos es que entienden
que nadie puede hacerlo excepto nosotros. Nosotros somos lo que tenemos que hacerlo.
Podemos invitar a socios que nos puedan apoyar, pero nosotros tenemos que empezar.
Tenemos que reformar nuestros países, cambiar nuestros líderes,
hacernos más democráticos, estar más abiertos al cambio y a la información.
Y esto es lo que empezamos a hacer
en uno de los países más grandes del continente, Nigeria.
En realidad, si no estás en Nigeria, no estás en África.
Tenía que decirlo.
(Risas)
Uno de cada cuatro africanos subsaharianos es nigeriano,
y el país tiene 140 millones de personas dinámicas - gente caótica -
pero gente muy interesante. Nunca te aburrirás.
(Risas)
Lo que empezamos a hacer fue darnos cuenta
de que teníamos que tomar las riendas y reformarnos.
Y con el apoyo de un líder
que estaba, en ese momento, dispuesto a hacer las reformas,
expusimos un exhaustivo programa de reformas
que desarrollamos nosotros mismos.
No el Fondo Monetario Internacional. No el Banco Mundial,
en donde estuve trabajando durante 21 años y en donde llegué a ser vicepresidenta.
Nadie puede hacerlo por ti. Lo tienes que hacer tú mismo.
Iniciamos un programa que haría, uno: sacar el Estado
fuera de los negocios en los que no tenía nada que hacer -- no era asunto suyo estar en los negocios.
El Estado no debería estar en los negocios
de producción de bienes y servicios
porque es ineficiente e incompetente.
Así que decidimos privatizar varias de nuestras empresas.
(Aplausos)
Como resultado, decidimos liberalizar varios de nuestros mercados.
¿Podéis creer que antes de nuestra reforma --
que empezó a finales del 2003, cuando yo dejé Washington
para asumir el puesto de ministra de Finanzas --
teníamos una compañía de telecomunicaciones que sólo había sido capaz de desarrollar
4.500 líneas de tierra en sus 30 años de historia?
(Risas)
Poseer un teléfono en mi país era un gran lujo.
No podías conseguirlo. Tenías que sobornar.
Tenías que hacer cualquier cosa para conseguir un teléfono.
Cuando el Presidente Obasanjo apoyó y lanzó
la liberación del sector de telecomunicaciones,
pasamos de 4.500 líneas de tierra a 32 millones de líneas GSM, y siguen sumando.
El mercado de telecomunicaciones de Nigeria es el segundo más rápido en crecimiento del planeta,
después de China. Estamos recibiendo inversiones de aproximadamente 1 billón de dólares al año
en telecomunicaciones. Y nadie lo sabe, excepto unas pocas personas inteligentes.
(Risas)
La primera más inteligente en entrar
fue la compañía MTN de Sudáfrica.
Y en los tres años que fui ministra de Finanzas,
tuvieron una media de 360 millones de dólares de beneficio anual.
360 millones en un mercado -- en un país que es un país pobre,
con una media de ingresos per cápita por debajo de los 500 dólares.
Así que el mercado está ahí.
Ellos lo ocultaron, pero pronto otros lo llegaron a conocer.
Los mismos nigerianos empezaron a desarrollar
algunas compañías de telecomunicaciones sin cable,
y han emergido tres o cuatro más.
Hay un mercado enorme ahí fuera,
y la gente no sabe nada de él, o no quiere saber.
Así que la privatización es una de las cosas que hemos hecho.
La otra cosa que también hemos hecho es administrar mejor nuestras finanzas.
Porque nadie va a ayudarte y a apoyarte
si no estás administrando bien tus propias finanzas.
Y Nigeria, con el sector petrolífero, tenía la reputación
de ser corrupta y de no manejar bien sus propias finanzas públicas.
Así que, ¿qué es lo que tratamos de hacer? Introdujimos una ley fiscal
que desvinculaba nuestro presupuesto del precio del petróleo.
Antes solíamos presupuestar cualquier
porque el petróleo es el mayor sector, el que proporciona más ingresos
en la economía: el 70 por ciento de nuestras ganancias viene del petróleo.
Desvinculamos eso, y una vez lo hicimos empezamos a hacer presupuestos
a un precio ligeramente inferior que el del precio del petróleo
y a ahorrar todo lo que estuviera por encima de ese precio.
No sabíamos que podíamos llevarlo a cabo; fue muy controvertido.
Pero lo que inmediatamente conseguimos fue que la volatibilidad
que había estado presente en términos de nuestro desarrollo económico -
en donde, incluso si los precios del petróleo eran elevados, podríamos crecer muy rápido.
Cuando ellos se desplomaban, nosotros también.
Y nosotros apenas podíamos pagar nada, ningún salario, en la economía.
Eso se resolvió. Fuimos capaces de ahorrar, antes de que yo me marchara,
27 millones de dólares. Mientras que -- y esto fue a nuestras reservas --
cuando yo llegué en 2003, teníamos siete billones de dólares en reservas.
Cuando me fui, habíamos alcanzado casi los 30 billones de dólares.
Y en estos momentos, tenemos unos 40 billones de dólares en reservas
gracias a la correcta administración de nuestras finanzas.
Y eso refuerza nuestra economía, la hace estable.
Nuestra tasa de intercambio, que solía fluctuar constantemente,
es bastante estable y está siendo administrada ahora, así que los empresarios
pueden predecir los precios en la economía.
Bajamos la inflación del 28 por ciento hasta el 11 por ciento.
Hicimos crecer el PIB de una media de 2.3 por ciento la década anterior
hasta el 6.5 por ciento ahora.
Así que todos los cambios y reformas que pudimos hacer
se han visto reflejados en resultados que son medibles en la economía.
Y lo que es más importante, porque queremos alejarnos del petróleo
y diversificarnos -- y hay tantas oportunidades
en este gran país, como en muchos países de África --
lo que fue remarcable es que gran parte de este crecimiento vino
no sólo del sector petrolífero, sino del no petrolífero.
La agricultura creció más del 8 por ciento.
A medida que las telecomunicaciones crecían, también lo hacían la vivienda y la construcción.
Y podría seguir. Esto es para mostraros que
una vez tienes resuelta la macroeconomía,
las oportunidades en otros varios sectores son enormes.
Disponemos de oportunidades en la agricultura, como ya dije.
Disponemos de oportunidades en minerales. Poseemos gran cantidad de minerales
en los que nadie nunca ha invertido o explorado. Y nos dimos cuenta
que sin la correcta legislación para hacerlo posible,
eso no pasaría. Así que ahora tenemos un código minero
que es compatible con varios de los mejores en el mundo.
Disponemos de oportunidades en la vivienda y el sector inmobiliario.
No había nada en un país de 140 millones de personas --
no había centros comerciales tal como los conocéis aquí.
Ésta fue una oportunidad de invertir para alguien
que estimuló la imaginación de la gente.
Y ahora, estamos en una situación en la cual los negocios en este centro comercial
están facturando cuatro veces más de lo que habían proyectado.
Así que, hay enormes posibilidades en la construcción, en el sector inmobiliario,
en los mercados hipotecarios. Servicios financieros:
poseíamos 89 bancos. Demasiados sin hacer negocios reales.
Los consolidamos de 89 a 25 bancos requiriendo
que aumentaran su capital -- capital compartido.
Y éste fue de unos 25 millones de dólares a 150 millones de dólares.
Los bancos -- estos bancos están ahora consolidados, y este fortalecimiento
del sistema bancario ha atraído grandes cantidades de inversiones provinentes del exterior.
El Barclays Bank del Reino Unido está trayendo 500 millones.
El Standard Chartered ha traído 140 millones.
Y podía seguir. Dólares, fluyendo, dentro del sistema.
Estamos haciendo lo mismo con el sector de las aseguradoras.
Así que en servicios financiero, existen grandes oportunidades.
En turismo, en muchos países africanos, una gran oportunidad.
Y por eso es por lo que mucha gente conoce África oriental:
por la vida salvaje, los elefantes, etcétera.
Pero administrar el mercado turístico de tal forma
que pueda beneficiar realmente a la gente es importante.
Así que ¿qué es lo que estoy tratando de decir? Estoy tratando de deciros
que hay una nueva ola en el continente.
Una nueva ola de apertura y democratización en la cual, desde el 2000,
más de dos tercios de los países africanos han tenido
elecciones democráticas en las que han participado diferentes partidos políticos.
No todas ellas han sido perfectas, o lo serán,
pero la tendencia es muy clara.
Estoy tratando de deciros que desde los últimos tres años,
la tasa media de crecimiento del continente ha pasado
del 2.5 por ciento hasta el 5 por ciento anual.
Esto es mejor que el rendimiento de muchos de los países de la OCDE.
Por lo tanto, está claro que las cosas están cambiando.
Los conflictos están disminuyendo en el continente;
de unos 12 conflictos hace una década,
hemos bajado a unos tres o cuatro conflictos,
uno de los más terribles, está claro, es Darfur.
Y, ya sabes, existe el efecto contagio en el que
si algo está pasando en una parte del continente,
parece que el continente entero esté afectado.
Pero deberías saber lo que este continente no es --
es un continente de muchos países, no un país.
Y si hemos bajado hasta tres o cuatro conflictos,
eso significa que hay muchas oportunidades en las que invertir
en economías estables, crecientes y apasionadas
en donde existen muchas oportunidades.
Y quisiera apuntar sólo una cosa sobre esta inversión.
La mejor manera de ayudar a los africanos hoy en día
es ayudarlos a mantenerse por sí mismos.
Y la mejor manera de hacer eso es ayudándoles a crear puestos de trabajo.
No hay ningún problema en luchar contra la malaria y poner dinero en eso
y en salvar las vidas de los niños. Eso no es lo que estoy diciendo. Eso está bien.
Pero imaginad el impacto en una familia: si los padres tienen trabajo
y pueden asegurarse de que sus hijos van al colegio,
y que pueden comprar medicamentos para luchar contra la enfermedad por ellos mismos.
Si podemos invertir en lugares en los que podais hacer dinero
a la vez que crear puestos de trabajo y ayudar a la gente a mantenerse por sus propios medios,
¿no es ésa una oportunidad maravillosa? ¿no es ése el camino a seguir?
Y quisiera decir que algunas de las mejores personas en las que invertir
en el continente son las mujeres.
(Aplausos)
Tengo aquí un CD. Siento no haber dicho nada cuando todavía tenía tiempo.
De lo contrario, me hubiera gustado que lo hubierais visto.
Dice así, "África: abierta al negocio."
Y en realidad éste es un video que ha ganado un premio
como el mejor documental del año.
Tengo entendido que la mujer que lo hizo
va a estar en Tanzania, en donde van a hacer una sesión en junio.
Nos muestra que los africanos, y en particular las mujeres africanas, quienes
en contra de todo pronóstico han desarrollado negocios, algunos de talla mundial.
Una de las mujeres en este video, Adenike Ogunlesi,
hace ropa para niños --
lo que empezó como un hobby y creció hasta convertirse en un negocio.
Mezclando materiales africanos, tales como los que tenemos,
con materiales de otros lugares.
Así que, ella te hará un par de pequeños petos de pana,
con materiales africanos mezclados. Diseños muy creativos.
Ha alcanzado un nivel en el cual incluso tuvo un pedido de Wal-Mart.
(Risas)
De 10.000 prendas.
Esto muestra que tenemos gente que es capaz de hacerlo.
Y las mujeres son diligentes: están centradas; trabajan duro.
Podría seguir dando ejemplos:
Beatrice Gakuba de Rwanda, que abrió una floristería
y está ahora exportando a la subasta holandesa en Ámsterdam cada mañana,
y que está empleando a otras 200 mujeres y hombres para trabajar con ella.
Aun así, muchas de ellas necesitan capital para expandirse,
porque nadie cree, fuera de nuestros países,
que podemos hacer lo que es necesario. Nadie piensa en términos de mercado.
Nadie piensa que hay oportunidades.
Pero yo estoy aquí hoy para decir que esos que pierdan este barco ahora,
lo van a perder para siempre.
Así que si quieres estar en África, piensa en invertir.
Piensa en las Beatrices, piensa en las Adenikes de este mundo,
que están haciendo cosas increíbles, que las están llevando
hasta la economía global, mientras que al mismo tiempo se aseguran
de que sus conciudadanos y conciudadanas tienen un empleo,
y de que los niños de esos hogares reciben educación
porque sus padres están ganando unos ingresos adecuados.
Así que os invito a que exploréis las oportunidades.
Cuando vayáis a Tanzania, escuchad atentamente,
porque estoy segura de que oiréis hablar de las diferentes oportunidades que van a haber
para que os involucréis en algo que puede hacer un bien
para el continente, para la gente y para vosotros mismos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)